Can you talk about what is the idea of succession?
What are the odds that it might happen?
What does it mean for the United States? Uh,
in some way for different States to succeed?
Sure. America has been one country with several cultures since the beginning.
Um,
there's absolutely no reason for someone this goes back to the anarchist idea.
If you despise Donald Trump, which is your prerogative,
if you think Joe Biden is a clown, which is your prerogative,
there's absolutely no reason for you to be governed by someone you disapprove of
this is a incoherent nonsensical concept.
The only reason we even take it as a hypothesis is that we're trained to the
contrary since kindergarten, um, uh, succession.
I don't know what along what lines,
but increasingly it's becoming harder and harder for people to have
conversations. I think social media,
and this is something people despise social media for.
I think this is something that social media has done well,
which I am advocating for is it tends to kind of run through
ideas through like an evolutionary process and drive them to the logical
conclusion. Uh, so it's very hard to be a moderate online,
cause there's gonna be people, you know,
pushing through your ideas through several cycles and then you're gonna end up
at some kind of more pure, or if you want to dislike it extreme perspective,
having these different pockets,
it's not really governable because people fundamentally have different
worldviews. So I don't know what's the session would look like.
I think the number is really
increasing at an exponential rate. Um, I do not number of supporters,
supporters.
I think the claim that this can only be accomplished through violence is false.
It's a lie. Uh,
just like any divorce doesn't have to involve beating your ex-husband or
ex-wife. So, and I,
I I'm very much looking forward to this becoming a reality far
quicker than I ever expected.
Well, do you think there's a value of, um,
competing,
worldviews being forced to be in the
same yes.
Context?
So we can agree if group one thinks a,
B and C are the fundamental aspects of their worldview and argue within that and
world group two things D E and F and argue with them that,
so you're going to have a lot of argument within those space,
but if there's fundamental differences in worldview,
there's no reason to be,
especially when each views the other as completely coherent and, and reasonable.
Do you think there's a line of fundamentally different
worldviews that, uh,
along which the succession will happen in the United States? Like,
is there something that emergency you as a set of ideas that are like,
um, what do you call that? Like, you can't come to a,
you can't come to an agreement over.
I, yeah, I think this is already happening. Like with the, um,
I think there's just two fundamental perspective and each one thinks the other
is insane and also deadly and destructive.
And I don't see how there's any, um, discourse on this topic.
So on the left, I wouldn't say it's left versus right.
I think it's people who are pro risk versus people who are risk averse.
Yeah. So risk averse. And then there's like a, uh, uh,
hope for the comfort of the sort of, uh,
centralized science, uh, giving the truth.
And then everybody must follow the truth right. Of, uh,
the proper way to behave. And then there's a, on the other side,
a distrust of any kind of centralized institutions of anybody
who might, uh, use, uh,
like control to try to gain greater and greater power and masks are a symbol of
that. And even if masks are, are not a,
uh, effective way of, uh, of stopping the virus,
which is really unfortunate to me as a, from a perspective,
I happened to be on a survey paper about masks.
Like people don't seem to care about the data or the so on it's this, this,
this has become just a nice point on which to then highlight the
difference between, uh, the two, the two sides. Yeah. That's really interesting.
I mean.
I it's, it.
Sounds kind of on the face kind of ridiculous that the succession would occur
over masks.
It wouldn't,
but I'm saying this is an example of something where there's a clean break. Yes.
Um, and, and risk averse versus, you know, uh,
someone who's risk seeking.
These are just two fundamentally different perspectives.
Do you want to have an NHS or do you have a,
one of a market-based healthcare system you can make very valid arguments for
both. There's no reason for everyone to be under one.
You think that's not something that's that you think that's irreconcilable?
If that's the word. Yeah. Uh,
that that's not in the space of ideas that you can have in the same room
together, and they fight each other and ultimately make progress. Like they,
that succession is the more effective way to proceed forward. Yes.
Well, I, uh,
do you see a possible world would knows the answer,
meaning, uh, I know you say yes,
because you kind of lean on the side of freedom and are anarchism. Yes.
Like you make, you want to make,
let me make an argument in terms of divorce,
which is in your worldview or your intuition is you want to
make succession as frictionless as possible. Like along all lines,
not just like States or whatever, just like absolutely. You want to choose,
you want to be free. Yeah. And peaceful. Let me make my authoritarian,
uh, Russian Papa stallion argument in terms of
relationships, like when goes wrong in a relationship,
not your language. Okay.
There's only a place for once thought at this table. Okay. Okay.
I'll get to you Lennon. You know, you get to be like,
Merkel is our previous discussion with gluten. Okay. The only me only the hands,
uh, it, you know,
you want to work through some of the troubles before you get divorced.
Like you want to do the work and relationships sometimes.
Like it goes up and down, like in 200 plus years, it's, uh, it's done,
but in the listen, okay. So it's not a one night stand, but you know,
look at it.
Trump, this, I don't see the middle ground.
He's either a complete calamity buffoon,
or he's been the first grade president we've had in many, many years.
So you think that there's something different now than it was 20 years ago? Yes.
Social media and access to information.
And the division will only increase you think, Oh yes.
So Trump is not an accident of history. So zebra.
Thought Trump was the river, but he was the dam.
Trump was the dam. They thought he was the river.
So not analogy Trump being gone makes things worse.
Yeah.
For them perspective, because now that things are really going to hit the fan.
So what are the odds of succession? I don't know.
And my desperate hope is that it's peaceful.
But I think the number of people who are becoming very comfortable with the
violence is making me very unsettled.
Well, I see words as violence and your Twitter.
It's like Hiroshima is a million. Uh,
sometimes I curl up in the corner crying after I check your Twitter feed.
So, but you in, uh, in all seriousness,
you, um, you think is possible to do non-violence session.
It's a bit Czechoslovakia.
Look at Brexit. Brexit was the succession.
Right? Right. So you can have.
Civil war did not need to be fought.
That would have been a non-violence session. And if you worry about slavery,
you could have bought off all the slaves, import them to the North.
It still would have been cheaper and less loss of life and probably better for
race relations.
Yeah. I don't know enough history to,
to wonder about like how the civil war could have been avoided. Well,
that's how is a well conversation?
So like, no, no, no.
If they want us to seed say, look, here's what we're going to do.
We're going to let you succeed. But you have to end up slate.
You have to end slavery. They succeeded because of slavery. Here's the thing.
This is like this. Some circles of conservatism have this myth that, Oh,
it wasn't about slavery is about States' rights. Well,
if you go back every state, when they succeeded,
released a press release and they said, explicitly,
we're doing this because of slavery.
So that is an abomination that needs to be taken care of.
But the way the other countries have ended slavery,
one of the ways to do it is pay them by all.
And we ended up doing this after the war. I think the South people got, um,
reparations, the slave owners. It was just insane. Bring them North.
You want to go to cannon, whatever. And you agree. And that's our peace treaty
because the people who died, weren't the slave owners, it was white trash.
And it was that's who always, and I hate that. That's the term.
I can't think of a better one,
but that's who always ends up fighting these Wars often disproportionately it's
poor people and an educated people. And I don't, I don't,
I did not regard them as cannon fodder. I think it's horrible.
So what would it look like? There'll be two founding documents.
Yeah. They had their, they had their constitution.
Which I don't know the history of the, yeah.
They had a constitution, but it was much more decentralized.
If succession doesn't happen. Yeah.
You said that Donald Trump was the dam, not the river. Yeah.
The, that, that sounds like Walt Whitman or something.
You shouldn't it's poetry. Okay. And you flirting with me.
I don't, I w uh, w you know, we don't, we don't flirt.
We just go it's out in the club and drag you to the.
Cave.
And you don't want to know about the Sickles. It's not good cop, bad cop.
It's bad cop us. Yeah.
What do you think 2024 looks like, uh,
in terms of the candidates.
And it's going to be CommonWell Harris as the democratic candidate. Uh,
I'm really looking forward to Ted Cruz versus Mike Pence,
because they're both very good at debate. Um,
that would be interesting to see that differentiate themselves. But honestly,
I don't, I mean, things are going to get really ugly really soon.
What about Donald Trump coming back? He's not going to do it. Um, so things,
in my opinion, I think things are going to be really, really crazy in 2021.
And talk, talking about the dam being gone like.
20, 21. So this year going up.
Oh yeah. It's going to be complete. It's going to be complete mayhem.
You think, uh, like prediction wise and this is empirical.
What do you think Donald Trump's Twitter feed looks like
in 2021? Like, if we're at the end of 2021, we'll look back and see, like,
what was the, you know, Obama gate exclamation points,
or we won.
It's going to be for the first time in history,
holding the Republican party accountable to the, the base.
We've never had that happen before. I, uh,
I think he's going to be holding their feet to the fire, uh, radicalizing them,
uh, and given that they have the Senate where it's going to be 50, 50,
the Democrats have a three seat majority in the house.
This is not a governing coalition for either. Um,
it's going to be complete mayhem.
Does that actually look like, so w what are the key values?
Do you think that he's, he's going to try it again.
Um, I think it's just going to be very it's,
he's going to be holding them accountable in terms of budgeting,
even though he never did that as president. Uh,
I think in terms of some kind of nominations, here's the thing.
This is the first time since, um.
Uh, like S Nixon, uh.
50 Years and things weren't as politicized then where an incoming president
doesn't have control of the Senate.
The Senate has the vote over cabinet positions.
I do not see a possibility of them not trying to pick a fight on one or
two of these nominations. And that's going to,
and especially as we're venture Kavanaugh,
this is going to get very bloody very quickly. And I think Mitch McConnell,
there's a sadistic side to him. He revels in being the brakes on the car.
And I think the base is just going to be throwing just,
they're going to want some bone. It's like, Oh yeah, we,
we eliminated this one person.
So that's going to get really ugly really quickly.
You see it being quite diverse, like division increasing,
not stabilizing or decreasing. Uh, and I'll be doing my part.
I know you'll be doing my part when I'm trying to do my part. And like,
trying to beak, like, to me, the division is, uh,
shouting over, uh, people like Elon Musk, uh,
people who are actually building stuff and like accomplishing things in this
world in terms of like Ilan said, he took the red pill,
not see, you're talking about the,
I'm talking about forgetting Elon SpaceX and Tesla. And, uh,
actually the good size of like some of the things that Google is doing, uh,
like actually building things, like making the world's information, searchable,
all that kind of stuff. Like all this stuff, you know,
the making actually the world a better place.
There's a bunch of technologies that are increasing our quality of life,
all this, all that kind of stuff. I feel like they get like,
not much credit or in our public discourse because of the
division there. Isn't just like,
like peop it's clouding our ability to concentrate on.
What's awesome about this world. Well.
You know, what would eliminate the division, right.
So session. Yeah. See, I don't, I don't,
it's hard for me to disagree.
It's hard to me to disagree because,
but at the same time succession, um, um,
I'm a romantic at heart and you want a divorce breaks my heart.
Cool. But do you want to live in a country? Yeah.
But do you wanna live in a country where Joe Rogan is regarded as an example of
someone who's spreading white supremacy?
I don't. Well, but see, I feel like that's not the country we live in.
That's just times.
Did it take a thedral does it on a regular basis? Well,
the cathedral is okay. The cathedral,
I guess you can maybe define the cathedral,
but it's like the centralized institutions that have like a story that they're
trying to sell.
Yeah. This is mold blocks concept, but yeah,
they basically are set the limits of permissible discourse and create a
narrative for the population to follow.
But to me, that's the minority of people.
Minorities always controlling everything in any country.
The vast majority of the masses have no thought.
Minorities can be overthrown in the circulation, the elites. Yeah.
The way the PR. And that's why the,
what progress looks like is ridiculous. People take power and then,
uh, they get annoying and new ridiculous people that are a little bit better
overthrow the previous.
No, I think progress happens despite the people who were in power,
not because of them.
Right. And so why is the session? So is,
is it always about overthrowing the powerful? Is that how it progress?
No. I think progress happens despite the powerful,
the powerful are going to do what's in their power to maintain their power.
And they're going to fight innovation because it's a threat to their control.
There's always going to be the New York times of the world. Right.
There's always going to be those that have in their country.
So it's two countries. One has Joe Rogan, the other one has the New York times.
That's basically what's happening right now. It's just geographically,
this map out very well, but culturally. Yeah.
Yes. But that's just cultural stuff. Like there's a layer of public discourse.
Okay. I don't mean like, that's what we're operating under now,
but there's actual like progress being made like roads being built, uh,
hospitals being run, all those kinds of things.
Like the different innovations that seems like succession is counter
productive to that.
Right.
Cause one country would have all the roads and the other would have all the
hospitals. That's great.
No, that's not, that's not the point I'm trying to make. It's just like,
it just feels like the division that we're experiencing in the space of ideas
could be constructive and productive for,
for building better roads and better hospitals,
as opposed to like using that division to separate the countries,
they're all going to have to solve the same problems. It feels like, like sure.
But they can solve them differently and compete that way. Massive sample. Yeah.
That w we're seeing that right now,
different countries have different mass mandates and things like this.
And, uh,
the co competition within the same structure within the same founding documents.
And same as the Titians is not effective,
you think is as effective as separating.
Defective. But there is a certain point,
which I think we have long past where there is not a consensus governing
consensus, ideologically or culturally.